my question becomes now my question
becomes do you want a virgin then do you
want a virgin man well obviously not but
i'm not saying that i want someone
that's [ __ ] like 200 men i mean woman
i'm like i'm sorry that would be
that would be a man who's gay
but i always
there's biological reasons for the
reasons we feel the way we feel so the
reason that women i'm gonna i'm gonna
mute you
the reason the reasons why women are
attracted to men that have slept with
more women is because
like we want it was pre-selection so
before like we if a guy had a lot of
girls that was a sign
that he could take care of all those
women so like we are biologically
predispositioned to like a man that has
been with like more girls and i think
that is just
drink some water i think that
for women
to have someone that's a virgin it's
just like a
oh it's like a sigh like dang
they don't know what they're doing
because right it takes for a man it
doesn't take much to
please them for women it takes more
right he needs to know what the hell
he's doing right he doesn't have
experience it's going to be like okay
let me
you're going to have to teach yeah yeah
it's just going to take longer and i
feel like more females don't want to
take that process to
like to
help them out in that and
for men it's like
they don't
not related but you know maybe we should
no but the thing is like there's a
what's a term turning someone out like
you turn someone out but also
define that for me no like a man there's
someone else
no no i thought no okay i could could be
wrong but i thought it was a man who
gets with a woman who's kind of like i'm
shy blah and he kind of makes her into
like a quote-unquote freak if that makes
sense okay okay yeah yeah yeah
like turn in some like so men
would prefer
to quote-unquote make that happen
then a woman would try and make a man
into
do you know i mean a woman doesn't want
to teach a man
yeah
yeah how to have sex because it's just
it's so much more for a female and it's
like
it's like
i might take you to sex ed to teach you
how to please me
exactly so men
understand that and so when men are
having multiple sexual experiences in
general
they understand that yeah so when they
get to a woman and they have had
multiple sexual experiences they
understand that that's actually
attractive to women
now
i'm not saying that
having multiple sexual experiences is a
good thing or a bad thing i'm just
saying
us as men we understand that if we come
to a woman
and we don't know what we're doing
she's probably going to be like the [ __ ]
is this guy yeah
yeah what is he doing well and there's
there's biological reasons why we feel
the way we feel and we can't help like
you can't you can't really there's
biological reasons that we feel the way
we feel so we can't like necessarily
help it guys can't necessarily help that
they want more pure women especially in
this day and age i've had a lot of guys
wish they could turn that off
there are no pure women
oh
no i'm just saying like like generally
in the western world like women like
no i don't generally think that men
i don't think women generally think men
are pure
and i don't generally think that women
think
sorry men don't think women are pure and
women don't think men are generally pure
in this day and age you know i mean the
western culture yeah i don't yeah no
like if when someone says oh i'm single
i'm like
how many men you got your dms
but i don't lie like yeah all right
that's not just how many men you [ __ ]
that's available when was the last time
you had sex that's irrelevant
you don't think you don't think that's
you don't think that's relevant to a guy
to a guy let me let me okay okay okay
okay you keep cutting me off but it's
actually irritating me so
um no i'm saying you don't think it's
relevant to a guy that's asking you on a
date and he's courting you if you're
sleeping with someone else
i literally think it is
because because he's putting all if
you're not sleeping with the new guy
yeah if you're not sleeping with the new
guy he's putting all this time energy
and resources into you just to find out
you're giving it to the other guy for
free you know how irritating that is to
men
then they're like why am i doing all
this yeah yeah like like she understands
there's no because you're about to say
it depends on the relationship there's
no no you you would be upset if you're
going out of your way to spend time with
this dude and he's over here doing
whatever with this girl
no no no no it doesn't matter what type
of relationship it is if someone if
someone is putting in time you would be
upset if a friend is if you're putting
in all this time for this friend buying
them gifts showing how much you want
them
and then they're doing this for their
friend over here and they're doing
everything you're doing for them they're
doing for this friend you're like wait
why can't you do that for me and i'm
giving you that yeah but you're doing
this for this person over here that
don't really care about you but i care
about so psychology
but why do you you keep arguing the
exception like why
no because no it doesn't because we're
talking about in general there's
exceptions to every goddamn rule in
other words we're going to be here all
day if you just you're like what about
that exception and that except like why
do women do this they do this women
always remember always the exception
women will argue the 5 of the argument
when there's a whole 95 percent like for
one
actually exists
right
to make their point in their own
personal situation
know what all right so
if you were if you're a woman and you're
on a date with a man and this is the
difference between i think between men
and women
a woman's on date with a man man's on a
date with a woman
the woman asks when was the last time
you had sex
and the man says
a week ago
right
a woman's thinking
who the [ __ ] is that [ __ ]
a week ago
i like you on this date right now like
i'm trying to get to know you who you
are and if a woman on a date says to a
man you had sex a week ago and man's
thinking [ __ ] this [ __ ]
this is the last date we're going on
wait never happened
like if a woman would just say that's
what he's thinking i'm not saying it's
correct what i'm saying yeah because
because again there's biological reasons
yeah i'm like is that i thought this say
the same thing as him wait wait guys
let her go so if a woman were
oh sorry i saw the hiccups but so like
say like oh yeah i just had us had sex
with a woman like just a week ago and
then the woman you're on the same same
date with you're like she says oh yeah i
just you know same me too
same day would you see her differently
from the way you see yourself
100
yeah because because
because we've got over this we have
biological reasonings for the way we
feel how we feel there are double
standards and we are not the same
people double centers don't exist like
like we get into clothes
we don't have to pay on dates we get
into clubs for free we like we there's a
million scholarships for female like
female [ __ ] you know vip we only we only
complain about the few double standards
that there are and this double standard
is don't have sex with a guy within a
week that you're going on a date with a
new guy like that's not crazy guys
it's not crazy
it's not
if a guy knows that you've had sex even
in the last week and he's on a date with
you he's already said you know what he
didn't care
we're not going on another date even
though you were here if you've had
something
but they're not thinking that it's going
to be a long term thing they think
they're not thinking oh this is someone
who i could potentially be going into a
relationship with yeah
well well and it's bad for women too
because then women like half the time
like the girl's sleeping with the guy
she's actually in love with and then
like wasting all these other guys times
and she's not she can't even be open
with the new guy because she's still
like how is she supposed to be open with
these new guys and give him a chance
when you're you're sleeping with this
old guy that you actually want you know
what he's thinking he's thinking so
there's a guy that you had sex with a
week ago know that you're on a date with
me
he probably doesn't which means
you're probably going on dates with
other guys too why you're [ __ ] this
guy yeah they call themselves daddy's
yeah that is what the guy is thinking
i'm telling you yeah that's what you're
thinking yeah
and but i think this will pay off like
oh no we okay yeah a week ago
because women are wired differently from
men yeah because women want to know to
some degree
that you've got someone who
um is looking at you they want to know
that you've got someone who is kind of
feeling you so they can be the one
to trump all those other women yeah we
want to feel like we got we won yeah
yeah yeah yeah like
why would i want to go no
why would i want a guy that no one else
wants like you literally got like the
bottom of the barrel yeah yeah
the guy that you know when you cook rice
do you cook rice yeah you know that in
the pot you know when it's like burnt at
the bottom okay oh my god you've got
that guy yeah
you know why i think women's like dating
advice is so bad because because women
will say like oh you'll you're the prize
honey like but like if it's a guy you
want you're actually not the prize
because he can find a million of you you
know what i mean like beauty is common
and they expect like these these like
super attractive guys to like court them
like they're the only one and i'm not
saying like chase after guys that aren't
interested in you but like they always
tell girls like you're the prize don't
have to do anything
reject him and he'll still come after
you like i'm telling you a guy that
knows his worth right
knows that he's got
um
a thousand women that want him and you
have to be the one
i'm telling women you have to be the one
that makes him think
what is different about this girl than
the other thousand women
no no this woman's
ticking other boxes that the other
thousand women aren't aren't ticking
do you know what i mean yeah
because women essentially want a want
that like yeah i was saying they want
that top 15 10 guy yeah
a guy would go literally like
a co-op yep a guy would walk into co-op
see a woman
on
on a checkout and be like oh she's nice
and if that woman
ticks the boxes that he wants as a woman
he'd marry that woman
she doesn't have to be a woman who
she has to be she has to take certain
boxes he doesn't care if she is a
ceo of a company or if she is working on
a checkout if she ticks those boxes he's
down you know like that
that was always something hard for me
because i have a really strong work
ethic like my whole life that's like the
one thing that i've always been
complimented on this i work like very
hard at what i do and it is hard to find
a guy that like works harder than me to
be honest like it's it's difficult and
it's always harder because like men
don't really value that as much as women
do well not hard work yeah like work
ethic
i
don't you just said if a girl is working
at like like the checkout
hang on
i want to understand that i'm saying
what men have great work ethic yes they
do right and like i'm saying like like
as a girl like i i work very hard like
i'm always like since i was a kid that
was the one thing like i've always been
complimented right i'm a very hard
worker and i said like sometimes it's
hard like in dating because that isn't
really valued to men i feel like like i
feel like it's working yeah yeah they
don't care one of the things that boxes
right right exactly but it's like um
i don't know sometimes you kind of wish
it was but it's just not how it is no
it's not i understand that it's really
not okay but it's because it's like like
then the guys that have that work ethic
do you know what that's valuable to you
other women yeah i know i know
it's valuable valuable to you yeah
more to you than